okay hi everyone so I often get this
mixed up and I will I always feel badly
when people mess up my name I call
Grandmaster Irina Crush Irina but I've
heard some people call her Irena so now
we're gonna get Irina or irina's answer
as to how she prefers to be called yeah
well the answer to that Sabina is that I
like all the pronunciations of my name
in every language every accent
um it's all good so in the US you
definitely hear Irina but the way you
say it is very nice and Irina or Irina
it's all good you know so um yeah you
can keep doing what you like Sabina all
right well you know how to calm down
Irina I I will keep calling you Arena
and hopefully you're rooting for her in
this tournament and others good luck to
everything and we'll see you guys soon